according to a recent study here now
with reaction are former Arkansas
Governor Mike Huckabee and Fox News
contributor Joe kcha thank you both
Governor uh do they just live in an
alternate universe is it just a good
talking point for MSNBC is this just his
covering his behind or do they really
believe that political violence is just
a trump
thing no he's just a big liar I mean
let's face it this is the guy that said
he could go to Walmart and smell the
people uh this is a person who has
nothing but contempt for people who are
conservative people who supported Trump
I call myself among them uh this is a
guy who is as corrupt as corrupt could
get who used the levers of government to
try to take down a sitting president
this guy ought to be in prison instead
he's out doing book deals and running
his chops on MSNBC which is no surprise
the big surprise is that there's
actually 3% of people who vote
Republican who are in the media I would
have guessed it to be even less than
that Joe I have a feeling we work with
maybe two and a half% of those uh I mean
it really is when you look at newsrooms
across the country
universally they they nod their head oh
yeah Peter stro yeah that's right yeah
yeah send in those send in those points
we we really agree with you I mean they
believe that one-sided
view well Pete why to the governor's
point is Peter stro on National
Television the guy who was fired from
the FBI who talked about insurance
policies about defeating Donald Trump in
2016 with his girlfriend Lisa Page who
was also on M MSNBC why is she s why are
they both serving as some sort of moral
compass Andrew mccab also fired from the
FBI gets a big fat contract from CNN and
we could go down the line as far as all
these Former Intelligence Officers who
are now you can't tell the difference
between Keith oerman and your basic
former FBI or CIA guy on MSNBC or CNN at
this point it makes you wonder when they
were in office and they were supposed to
be apolitical were they actually
apolitical while they were in those
positions that that that's just insane
as far as this whole poll that that that
came out as far as
3.4% of journalists saying that they're
Republican at this point let's say
you're a top J ISM student out of
college and I apply for a job at the New
York Times Washington Post CNN NBC News
and somewhere on my Facebook page or
LinkedIn page I share that I was part of
you know college Republicans or maybe I
supported some sort of Republican for
public office what do you think my
chances are being hired by any of these
so-called news organizations slim to
none so that's why I think there's
probably a couple of more conservatives
that are in journalism but they won't
admit it because they know they're never
getting another contract or getting
hired if they actually share that
information ah so they just have to stay
in the closet got it okay so stay in the
closet and you're good to go uh Governor
I mean I think I think Joe raises the
key Point yes Peter struck's a
commentator but he used to be at the top
of the FBI making these calls about a
sitting president and this would have
been his view then or his willingness to
bend the truth to pursue a political
ideology add that to the breaking news
we have tonight that Maine's Secretary
of State or Maine's a top political
appointment in in Maine is wanting to
pull Trump off the ballot I mean how far
are they willing to
go they're willing to do anything
anything it takes to stay in power
obviously they're willing to shred the
Constitution they're willing to just
declare somebody to be guilty of
something for which they've never been
charged and certainly not convicted and
to suffer the consequences would be like
saying about you Pete hey Pete you know
I know there's no evidence to it you've
not been charged with a crime but Joe
and I I've gotten together we're good
buddies and we've decided that you're
just a bad guy and that you don't
deserve to be on television anymore so
just wanted to tell you tonight you're
fired now do we have the authority to do
that of course we don't uh this is
absurd and I hope that the Supreme Court
will come to its Senses at the federal
level and throw this nonsense out 9 to
zero and tell these people to take a
basic Civics course ninth grade level
would be just fine they should be able
to understand it better if they
would I still can't help it Governor but
feel like I just got kind of fired by
Governor Huckaby uh on live television
deserve it or not I don't I don't know
but it sounded very very
authoritative uh Joe last word real
quick on what's going down in Maine
yeah let the people decide 312 days from
now right that's when the election
happens Pete and to allow the courts to
come in here and say no you can't vote
for somebody you may want to vote for is
a whole bowl of wrong but this will have
a boomerang effect to the governor's
point I have a feeling that the Supreme
Court even as biased as it is left and
right that it's going to come back 90
and once that happens then all of those
other ballots or all those other efforts
as far as legally to take Trump off the
ballot in Wisconsin and in Nevada and in
Georgia and in Arizona those will go by
the wayside and it will actually be jet
full jet fuel for the Trump uh campaign
as far as look see what these people are
trying to do the swamp is trying to take
me out let the people decide let them
vote I think this only helps Donald
Trump
ironically yeah it has the maralago raid
effect on his campaign as so many other
things have well as well Governor hakabe
Joe kcha thank you both hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else